we usually get up about 7:00 and I
usually get up a little later I make
coffee for both of us I like honey and
cream and I copy and then I almost
always drive to work our morning routine
is quite Monday oh yeah one thing we're
doing today is the fire-breathing dragon
finishing off that yeah and I've got
some stuff to blood and some skulls and
pumpkin I'm Marsha this is my husband
Edie
and we run distortions unlimited we make
monsters zombies aliens dragons and
feeds of all times oh my
most of what we make is scary I will say
that we make monsters for everyone from
home Haunter all the way up to amusement
park and big events all around the world
[Music]
we've been working together for 35 years
spin colonia yeah wonderful we started
out painting together I fell in love
very quickly we've been married almost
25 years we found a way to work together
I'm probably more on the business side
and it is probably more in the
production I can't tell you how many
people have told me I could never work
with my spouse and that's too bad
because you miss half or more of that
whole person's life if you don't
[Music]
I think people expect us to be a little
bit weirder than the yarn we're actually
a little bit boring when we get in the
car and go home it's over we love
monsters we just we've had enough of it
after a long day there's a separation
there there has to be you go crazy
somebody walked into our house they
wouldn't have a clue what we do in fact
we keep it all kind of secret if people
are surprised about that with us we like
it that way
it's really special to do something you
love with somebody you love we make
monsters but whatever our personalities
kind of mesh with each other so it works
out you know you really can establish a
good relationship as you're dripping
zombie blood that's the kind of woman I
need in my life
you
[Music]